merrill kelly will get the start for the
second time this year he pitched into
the seventh inning first time around and
brought a no-no into the set today bets
will lead off underway to finish up the
series between the dodgers and
diamondbacks and betts makes loud
contact to center but starling marte is
there max muncie digs in
chop shot right side for christian
walker and he'll toss to kelly for out
number two turner one for 11 in this
series
one of the best hitting third baseman
for years now that's a chopper up the
middle and he's gonna come through with
a two out single then there's this mvp
from last year a fourth round pick cody
bellinger sat yesterday he's ice cold to
start the year ballinger trying to snap
an 0 for 16. and ballinger smokes the
3-2 right field corner it's gone
welcome to 2020 cody his first home run
of the year a two-run shot and the
dodgers lead it two to nothing the 2020
debut comes a little late for clayton
kershaw but here he is back off the
injured list he was dealing with the
back stiffness and he is good to go
today
to start his year just to carry through
the zone the way the ball's coming out
of his hand we didn't see a lot of that
last year
going right after starling and striking
him out this is a good sign for the la
dodgers to see kershaw right out of the
box throwing the velocity right side
and clayton kershaw sits down this
fierce top of the order for the
diamondbacks welcome to 2020 clayton
kershaw with some heat and clayton
kershaw is ready to go for the second
inning coming off some heat in the first
how about that that's the hardest pitch
he's thrown at 93.1
in more than two years july of 2018.
left side
and chris taylor filling in for corey
seeger today nice pick by muncie for the
first out i'm telling you scott i i
didn't know that number about velocity
but it looks to me this is the best i've
seen clayton kershaw look stuff delivery
the ball coming out of his hand in a
couple of years he's fared very well
against calhoun
who does send it to right but betts
barely needs to move for out number two
carson kelly puts one on the ground to
the left side
six up six down clayton kershaw coming
back with authority so far and with one
out here comes bets
goes the other way and finds himself a
knock
so if he runs on calhoun he will off the
second he goes easily with a double five
tools from the man on second base
and he gets muncie to pop one up
and vargas is called off by peralta who
tumbles to make the catch two outs
mookie on second here's turner first
pitch sending it to right
and calhoun
camps under it for out number three
better work from kelly to work around
the bets double clayton kershaw back to
work here in the third six up six down
so far the fastball velocity is up the
confidence is certainly there and
kershaw picks up his third strikeout the
slider has replaced the fastball as
kershaw's best friend make that four
strikeouts clayton kershaw i think
dodger fans are gonna like what you're
gonna see kershaw's past 50 pitches now
first time we've seen him now in his
stress inning though so marty and walker
move up and with two outs cole calhoun
will dig in clayton kershaw picks up
strikeout number five he is sizzling in
the heat in arizona that's double back
in the third it's two and one to fall
behind against mookie betts can make all
the difference that's connects on the
2-1 deep right
and gone
splashdown
mookie betts with number two on the year
it's 3-0
mvp day at chase field bellinger home
run
bets
so far no runs allowed diamondbacks
looking for offense against clayton
kershaw in his 2020 debut the dodgers on
the best era as a team in baseball and
he got him fastball looked a little low
to ahmed
kershaw will take it why not six
strikeouts five scoreless
it's a good way to start your 2020 on
the mound
look who's back on the mound for the
dodgers another one for clayton kershaw
what was this conversation like
this is when you have three cy young
awards you get to decide whether you're
done or not he's obviously feeling good
turns on one easy does it for turner and
now he'll call it a day
a ruthian performance on the mound this
afternoon by clayton kershaw five and
two thirds three hits scoreless baseball
with six strikeouts clayton kershaw is
back in a big way mookievez removed from
this game edwin rios will take over at
the plate it looked like we saw him
wincing earlier this is the foul ball he
hit the home run later in the at-bat you
just hope with mookie this is
just being out of an abundance of
caution if there's anything there get it
checked out right now kenley janssen in
the ninth for the dodgers three
scoreless innings so far last chance
it's cole calhoun shipped to center
bellinger
back back
and has it too fast for the dodgers they
take three out of four from arizona
[Applause]